[Musique]
françois salaun me fais partie de ces
figures marquantes de l'art contemporain
au canada et les paître
et les poteaux grave danseuse
[Musique]
corey grave
moi j'ajoute très rapidement mer c'est
comme un état d'être pour elle je me
définis surtout comme peintre mais le
reste est important aussi
toujours en quête de nouvelles
expériences françoise sur les 25 salles
en italie au début des années soixante
dix et découvrent une scène artistique
bouillonnante ces images témoignent de
changements sociaux importants sur ce
graffiti le slogan des familles
italiennes
je suis comme je suis beaucoup de jeunes
étaient jaloux de ce qui s'était passé
dans les années 50 avec l'abstraction
picturale verts 68 72
c'était là conceptuel j'étais très
curieuse de ce qu'est parti de là et
j'ai abandonné la sculpture que je
faisais ce moment là pour faire des
recherches
alors je suis parti en italie j'ai une
bourse pour faire un film sur les
graffitis de robes elle découvre
notamment les revendications ouvrières
les mouvements étudiants c'est la montée
de la libération de la femme des grandes
causes de libération de la femme
l'avortement gratuit et elle se
passionne pour ses idées
traverser les années 70 de françoise
slovène s'était jetée l'éclairage sur
des dimensions je devrais plutôt que
politique d'une artiste en train de
prendre
je dirais certaine direction réfléchit
par rapport au monde
l'artiste est aussi mère monoparentale
l'exposition nous la montre avec ses
quatre fils à grévé inc andy où ils
s'intègrent naturellement à son travail
et à son oeuvre
madame seul even parlez-moi de ce
tableau tandis que mes enfants étaient à
l'école j'avais le loisir de me promener
d'un rhum et je suis allé un jour au
musée national de rome dans le musée
j'ai été je ne sais pas pourquoi mais
impressionné par un petit tableau de ce
jeune homme et j'y retournais souvent et
pourquoi il m'a fasciné c'est difficile
à dire en train mon fils me dit
aujourd'hui ils ont plus des photos de
nous à l'école et il me montre cette
photo et je dis mais je ressemble c'est
400 ans qui séparent de visage et elle
alla elle a ressenti de façon fort
intuitive cette connexion qui pouvaient
s'établir à travers le temps à travers
les cultures à travers une peinture est
une photographie donc ce sont de
multiples choses qu'elle à connecter
ensemble c'était comme si ça m'était de
données ça n'arrive pas souvent un
général marc une oeuvre d'art que ce
soit un tableau ou une oeuvre
conceptuelle ou ou autre chose
c'est beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
peine de désespoir par moments mais la
laisse tomber du ciel
une démarche commencé beaucoup plus tôt
en 1948 elle fait partie de ces jeunes
artistes qui signe le manifeste du refus
global huit hommes
cette fin
ils dénoncent les valeurs conservatrices
et religieuses et prône l'ouverture du
québec sur le monde et une plus grande
liberté
le document jugé scandaleux et très mal
reçue vous êtes l'une des co signataires
de ce manifeste refus global rédigé par
paul émile borduas c'est un cri de
révolte mais qu'est-ce que vous
revendiquez quand vous avez signé ce
manifeste
c'était la pression de l'église et du
gouvernement duplessis
quel impact ça a eu ce manifeste sur
vous les artistes il y à lui une sorte
de à quoi bon presse que paul émile
borduas qui était l'artiste plus mûr il
ne donne plus d'argent il a perdu sa
famille son poste d'enseignant et il a
été malade très malade pour la chanson
rappel inclurait je partais à paris avec
sa famille par hbo a eu de gros problème
il est parti pour new york je pense le
groupe s'est un peu d'effet ça vous a
découragé un peu mais il devient tous
continuer à vivre où il est oui
cette même année françois seul veine
fera découvrir aux québécois la danse
contemporaine une pionnière encore une
fois elle crée notamment danse sur la
neige
une oeuvre fondamentale dans sa carrière
filmé par jean paul riopelle
mais le film a été perdu
ici on la voit découvrir à rome le
magnifique temple circulaire des reculs
des photos inédites
je fais une pause autour de cet espace
et j'arrive au temple de recul
la plupart des divertissements à cette
époque peut être beaucoup plus politique
ça c'est très poétique aussi wii est
plus politique politique ce n'est jamais
quelque chose de pleinement scénarisé
ça joue sur le moment ça joue sur ce qui
se présente à elle devant ses yeux
dans un certain lieu et les choses se
mettant devant avec beaucoup de vérité
je dirai qu est ce qui vous pousse à
peindre encore aujourd'hui j'ai de la
chance d'être en bonne santé
j'ai de la chance d'avoir cette passion
vous travaillez toujours seul atelier
oui et je fais encore des grands
tableaux dont je suis fier quel est le
noeud si ce n'est
autre moi la plus grande de femmes
artistes canadiennes et salons de vie
fait qu'on profite encore d'elle et des
choses qu'elle a à nous dire
[Musique]